they've spoken twice by telephone in
recent days and still not been able to
bridge the gaps
boris johnson and ursula van der leyen
forced to admit the conditions for a
deal are simply not there
when the eu's chief negotiator michelle
barnier briefed eu ambassadors this week
he was described as being down beaten
gloomy with no tangible progress on the
three main sticking points of fisheries
a level playing field and dispute
resolution
so ahead of the leaders face-to-face
meeting in brussels
the negotiating teams have been asked to
step back take stock
and produce a summary report at that
stage
more than ever the brexit is a school of
patients even a university of patients
the work of the negotiating teams is
constrained by their own
respective mandates the political
leaders of course
have a little bit more leeway within the
bounds of their own political red lines
face-to-face talks may unlock the
impasse
or presented with a list of just how big
their differences are
the two leaders may end up admitting
defeat
most commentators regard the dispute
over fishing rights as solvable
where the two sides have run into more
trouble is issues of fundamental
principles
such as the concept of sovereignty to
access the eu's single market the uk
accepts it will have to abide by eu
standards and rules
but it bristles at the idea that the eu
could impose rules and sanctions
that seem overbearing you've got to be
you've got to be optimistic you've got
to believe that
there's the the power of sweet reason uh
to to get this thing over the line but
i've got to tell you
it's looking very very difficult at the
moment there may even be a third way
another stretching out of the already
stretched deadlines
it's looking very likely that the eu
will have to
use the procedure of a provisional
application
which would mean that the deal will
enter into force even if not
even if the ratification will not have
been
completed yet which throws up the risk
that if
one actor at eu side still have to
ratify in february or so that
the deal would be off and
would be null and void retroactively
which would be of course a legal
nightmare
the mood was certainly improved with
tuesday's news that the uk and eu
had reached agreement in principle on
border checks in northern ireland
with the result that the uk withdrew
contentious proposals
to override the legally binding brexit
withdrawal agreement
but the main talks remain on a knife
edge and a slightly better mood
may not be enough to overcome the
substantial differences
paul brennan al jazeera brussels